hey guys Pete here picking up with my
Game of Thrones season 8 problem series
today I'm gonna look at Queen Cersei of
House Lannister and the problems I see
with her story first a reminder that I
decided to do this series on problems
because the ending could go so many
different ways focusing on problems is a
way to work through it so it's not a
series saying Game of Thrones season 8
will be bad or Game of Thrones is so bad
now I think there's a good chance at the
end of the series we'll be one of the
high points of the show altogether even
though there are such high expectations
but when trying to sift through
everything we've learned reading and
rereading the books and what we've
learned watching and re watching the
show I find it hard to see what a good
ending will look like I'm doing the
Cersei video today because I started it
the other day and then I shelved it
because those new trailers came out I've
decided that I'm gonna do a general
ending of the story problems video next
since a lot of people disagreed with
what I said about Jon in that video in
this series I think I could have done a
better job explaining my point of view
overall so I think that making the
ending video next in the series rather
than at the end will kind of do that
either way I want to get through Cersei
today because I think she's a lot less
controversial I mean there are probably
some people out there rooting for Cersei
to win in the end
but only in the way that they're
probably always some people who are
cheering for the villain let's jump into
it Cersei Lannister is the current Queen
of the Seven Kingdoms
she took the Iron Throne for herself
after blowing up the septa bail or she
did that to destroy her enemies the high
Sparrow and Tyrells but it led her son
King Tommen to take his own life by
jumping out a window and the red key
Cersei swooped in to take his place and
thus far no one has been able to remove
her she may end up being the very last
person to ever occupy the throne but she
probably won't be allowed to see if
that's what is the case Tommen was the
last of her children Joffrey and
Marcella
died in season four and season five
respectively at the end of the seventh
season she became pregnant again
carrying what would be the fourth child
she's had with her twin brother Jaime
Lannister but I don't think that there
are many fans out there that expect her
to you know actually have that child I
mention all of this because it leads us
into the first problem the number one
problem with Cersei is that she is a
true villain it's not to say she isn't a
complex character she is and we'll talk
about that some later but she is
definitely a bad guy as far as the story
goes her villainy has been somewhat
restrained because she was also a mother
who wanted to protect her children but
at this point there is nothing holding
her back at all it should be said that
she's a good villain a really good
billion in fact and I'm not saying that
she's some kind of diabolical mastermind
she's not she actually makes a lot of
mistakes what I mean is that even though
there isn't much to like about what she
does she's still a likable character or
at least an enjoyable character to watch
I've talked about this in plenty of
videos before Cersei is one of my
favorite characters in the show a lot of
that is Lina Hetty's performance which
is amazing but part of it is also dare I
say the way that they adapted her
character for TV last week I was going
through her chapters and a feast for
crows and I was reminded about the
differences in the book and show
versions usually when you say that the
comparison is how much better the book
version is but in Circe's case it's
actually the opposite in the chapters
where we get them from Circe's point of
view get insights into why she's doing
things most of this is just related to
her paranoia and it makes her a little
less sympathetic to me like she's not as
cunning she's just desperate maybe is
the way you could say that she has the
same motivations more or less but it
comes across better on the screen it's
sort of like when I'm reading I'm
thinking I got these you know I'm
reading the chapters I got this voice in
my head saying you're bringing this all
on yourself you paranoid idiot but when
I watch her on the show I'm just like
damn that's cold you know it's like she
just is more
I think is what I would say on the show
to earn any pob chapters from Cersei
until the later books though so you
actually get to know her through the
other characters perspectives and it's
pretty much the same in the beginning of
the books as it is and the first you
know seasons of the show anyway so it's
not like they made some big decision to
do it that way it just turned out that
way for the most part as far as I can
tell but I do think that they've
continued to write her pretty well and
like I said Lena Headey does a really
great job of delivering it but yeah I
mean after Joffrey dies in the books
more or less you start to get into her
head and point-of-view chapters and it's
not a good look if you haven't read the
books it's not really that important in
relation to where we are now but the
show version the super fun to watch
Cersei is the villain like the villain
and she has nothing to hold her back
from doing everything she can to hold on
to her power she's a bit of a cornered
animal this is the second problem with
Cersei just like I said in my night king
problems video about him she can't
possibly win because she's full-on
villian mode and she has nothing to lose
there really isn't a path to redemption
I mentioned this in a previous video but
it's a good time to bring it back up one
of the biggest things that stood out to
me when I watched the first trailer over
and over again was that Cersei had
positioned herself to be the real threat
in a world where there is magical night
king coming to destroy humanity
she has positioned herself to be the
bigger threat in that trailer you see an
existential threat approaching
Winterfell we see our heroes getting
ready to fight the Battle of their lives
in order to save mankind in the midst of
that we get that shot of Cersei with the
satisfied look on her face where she's
standing next to Qyburn and it's just
like [ __ ] you know some people are worse
than magical armies of the dead
some people will use that threat for
their own personal gain her brother
Jaime couldn't even get on board with
that idea and he had stuck with her up
until that point in the show and the
books they fall out earlier and she's
also much
more cruel towards him like I forgot
about that a little but show Jamie has
remained loyal until she crossed this
line of course this only adds to her not
having anything left to lose or anything
to hold her back
she's already done a lot of terrible
things I mean she had her husband killed
when she blew up the septa bail or that
was not just her enemies inside there
were a lot of innocent people involved
as well her dwarves getting their heads
cut off all over the place and her name
when she was trying to get hearings head
and that's just to name a few of the
things but going back on her word here
his point of no-return territory she's
only looking to hold on to her power and
there is no version of an ending that
can have her keep that power and still
be a good ending and this leads us to
the biggest problem of Cersei story how
does she get a fitting ending she is the
villain and she has to lose and I think
that means she has to die but there is
some complexity lurking in her story at
the same time on the one hand Shore she
was born into a rich family and she's
universally described as beautiful in
the books which makes her situation a
lot better than most of the other
inhabitants of Westeros I mean she is
born at the top of the food chain for
the most part that also meant that her
primary function was to be married off
to another family in order to improve
the standing of House Lannister in the
system that they live in that's the way
things are in that world and even
highborn women are unable to escape that
part of her conflict lies in that you
know she's aware that she isn't treated
as an equal because she's born female
she brings this up several times and
story and it drives some of her
decision-making but what really drives
Cersei is prophecy she grows up thinking
she's going to marry Prince Rhaegar like
her father tells us her this at a very
early age and that's kind of interesting
when you think about it because Rhaegar
is another character who was driven by
prophecy and he did all sorts of things
that caused a lot of other stuff to
happen in the idea that he was trying to
follow a prophecy but she never ended up
marrying Rhaegar because
tenaris is dead king aerys aka the mad
king he started to get him in Thailand
Circe's father were friends for a very
long time since childhood and they had
this weird power dynamic as Aerys got
older and got weirder and matter so he
wouldn't let it happen
but you know when she initially goes the
see Maggie the Frog that's who she's
talking about when she asked one why Wed
the Prince it's not really clear when
the prophecy took over her life but we
do know that Maggie said one of the two
girls didn't have a future and that
Melara her companion there that was the
other girl died that night just as
Maggie predicted this could either be
when Cersei started to worry about the
prophecy turning out to be true or she
may have played a part in Melara falling
into the well in an effort to stop her
from repeating what they heard so either
way it had an effect on her fright from
the start but it's interesting because
everything maggie has said turned out to
be right as far as we can tell her
paranoia has had a natural progression
as each new part comes true and by the
time we get inside her head she is
consumed by it and the decisions that
she makes are all influenced by it she's
sure Tyrion is the balan car she saw
margery is the younger more beautiful
Queen and this causes her to set things
in motion with the sparrows she's trying
to get rid of Margery because she thinks
if she can stop that part of the
prophecy then everything else will be
done so that's pretty tragic right and
her mind she's making all these
decisions because she wants to protect
her remaining son she thinks this I mean
she even says it out loud you know she's
going around doing things and she's
saying I'm doing it to protect Tommen
and she's been through a lot at this
point she's married off to Robert and
doesn't go well by the time we meet them
in the show we can tell it's a loveless
marriage but we also learned that he was
pretty abusive in the bedroom especially
in the early years of their marriage
from the books she has a child that she
clings on to as her one good thing and
he turns out to be a sadistic psycho he
dies her father gets killed by her
brother I mean it's not nothing like
there's a lot of bad stuff that happens
to her she does all sorts
terrible things in a paranoid response
that gets her locked up by the zealous
that she gave power to she has to do a
walk of shame naked in front of everyone
I mean there is actual complexity here
right and she's terrible like I said
she's done what she's done in that true
sense of everyone is the hero in their
own story she had her reasons
she did what she thought she had to do
based on her situation but none of what
she suffered really makes any of that
stuff okay in the walk of atonement
sequence in the books she thinks about
Ned when you know she's out in the front
of the septa bail or she thinks about
how if Joffrey just hadn't followed
through with his beheading you know how
different the story would have turned
out when she dreams of the trip to see
Maggy the Frog she tells herself to turn
around to not listen to him Aggie has to
say you know it's sort of like she is an
actual victim like stuff happens to her
but she also embodies it to the sense
that she turns an outward and she just
brings destruction you know what I mean
like it's not she doesn't work on these
things constructively so I guess you
know on one hand you think you kind of
feel bad for because like I said she's a
compelling character and bad stuff has
happened to her but at the same time
like she's ruthlessly evil and there's
no chance that she's going to do the
right thing like you just know that
there's no way she's gonna walk away you
know I mean she's not gonna give up
power she's not gonna go out without a
fight
she'll take everyone down if that's what
is the only option so you know how do we
get a fitting ending to that like I want
to see at least a nod to the complexity
of who she was but I mean for me like I
would almost like to see her recognize
the folly of the way that she's done the
things that she's done you understand
like I think if she realizes that yeah
you know all this bad stuff happened to
her and then she went out and did all
this other terrible stuff but you know
she did that it's sort of like you know
she she kind of thinks of herself as not
responsible because of things that have
happened to her so it'd be really cool
if there's some kind of dialogue
or her ending where she realizes you
know what I did this because I mean she
kind of had that point a bit whenever
she turned the tables on septa unella
but I don't know it would be nice to see
her have some kind of a coming home
inside before she has to actually pass
on I mean I just don't think that she
can live I don't think she's gonna turn
anything around nobody would trust her
if she did at this point so what do you
guys think do you care do you see her as
a tragic complex character or you just
see her as pure evil and you want to see
her go because it'll be fun to watch the
bill and die
I don't know I'm really interested to
see what you think I will definitely be
sad whenever i watch the character pass
on like it will be a strange moment
because I mean I want it to happen like
I definitely don't want her story to go
any other way but it'll be interesting
because it's someone that you've
followed and thought about and really
liked even though they were terrible for
so many years now and you know and she's
gonna have to go and it's gonna be
interesting so like the video if you
enjoyed it like I said I am going to do
a general problem with the endings video
next I'm gonna try to get that out real
soon so if you want to follow along you
can subscribe you know what to do there
thanks for watching guys I will talk to
you soon